et nous avons retrouvé françois-xavier
bellamy bonsoir donc peut-être de liste
des républicains je le disais aux
élections européennes vous êtes à
marseille on va parler des européennes
dans un instant mais à un mot sur les
annonces des manuels macron ce soir
est-ce qu'il faut parler d'ailleurs
selon vous de virage écolo de la part du
président et vous et moi je suis assez
frappé de ces annonces d'abord on ne
découvre pas à l'instant la question de
la biodiversité qui est une question
fondamentale on en parle déjà les
scientifiques en parle depuis très
longtemps les politiques aussi on se
souvient de l'avertissement de jacques
chirac lancé à la tribune des nations
unies
et ce qui est d'autant plus frappant
c'est que les mesures qui sont annoncées
ce soir par le président de la
république faisait quand même parti pour
une immense majorité d'entre elles d'un
grand plan qui avait été annoncé en 2018
avec nicolas hulot avec ce gouvernement
on a du mal à comprendre cette situation
sinon en la rapprochant malheureusement
de ce que bruno jeudy disais à l'instant
je le crois une situation de difficulté
électorale qui fait qu' on a besoin
d'utiliser à des fins électoralistes ce
sujet pourtant décisif françois-xavier
bellamy s'est malgré tout l'écologie
devenait le thème de campagne de deux de
ses européenne a jusqu'au jusqu'au 26
mai serait pas forcément une bonne
nouvelle pour vous ce n'est pas le sujet
de prédilection de votre campagne
si si c'est un sujet majeur pour nous
nous défendons depuis le début de cette
campagne c'est à dire depuis que j'ai eu
l'occasion d'être investi 1 b cagnes et
séverine avec arnaud danjean au coeur de
notre projet nous défendons
l'installation d'une barrière écologique
pour rééquilibrer la mondialisation et
pour mettre fin à cette situation
effectivement dans laquelle nous causons
le déséquilibre climatique et écologique
que que nous déplorons mais encore une
fois je crois que il faut pas se laisser
duper par ces grosse ficelle
électoraliste c'est un sujet majeur pour
nous c'est un sujet qui mérite un peu
sérieux et autre chose que de la mise en
scène et je regrette encore une fois que
nicolas hulot qui a quitté ce
gouvernement parce qu'il jugeait que son
engagement et écologiques n'étaient pas
suffisamment consistant avait avait déjà
présenté ses mesures
on nous les représentent aujourd'hui
comme s'il s'agissait d'une découverte
rappelons quand même que le gouvernement
sur bien des dossiers parlons de la
question des aires marines par exemple a
accepté de sacrifier par exemple à
l'éolien offshore
une préoccupation écologique pourtant
fondamentale
c'est vraiment assez désolant de voir
que effectivement à trois semaines de
l'élection européenne tout est fait pour
dissimuler le vrai débat européen qui
est nécessaire qu'ils intègrent la
question écologique mais tellement
d'autres sujets et qu'il faudrait
maintenant partager largement et je
regrette pour ma part que y compris sur
cette question écologique la république
en marche n'est pas encore dévoilé son
projet européen elle ne dévoilera à
quinze jours du scrutin ça ne me paraît
ni très sérieux ni très loyal vis-à-vis
des français qui doivent faire un vrai
choix pour cette élection européenne
alors vous êtes la surprise de cette
campagne des européennes nous est
crédité de 14% en moyenne d'intentions
de vote et ce week-end le figaro
magazine titrait la droite est de retour
est ce que le bon titre n'aurait pas dû
être une droite est de retour
non c'est la droite et justement je
crois pas que ce soit lié à ma personne
c'est lié vraiment à toute une équipe
qui incarne la droite aujourd'hui dans
cette campagne
j'ai été investi je le disais dès le
début de cette campagne avec agnès evren
avec arnaud danjean et nous sommes
rejoints aujourd'hui maintenant par des
policiers qui porte
on le voit ce soir à marseille partout
en france cette famille politique avec
un projet clair une vision forte et
assumée depuis le début de cette
campagne nous sommes là pour parler du
fond nous sommes là pour parler d'europe
et ça n'est pas effectivement une droite
qui se présente à cette élection c'est
toute notre famille politique rassemblée
avec les centristes d'hervé morin et
c'est ce qui fait je crois la force de
cette dynamique que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui
c'est ce rassemblement de la droite et
du centre cette union pour pouvoir
refonder l'europe et pour pouvoir
rétablir la france bruno jeudy bel ami
bruce toussaint le disais à l'instant
vous êtes la surprise de cette de cette
campagne vous êtes crédité de 14 à 15 %
suivant les instituts de sondage on est
quand même loin des 20% de françois
fillon en 2017 et même des 20% de feu
l'ump en 2014 lors des mêmes élections
européennes qu'est ce que ça vous
inspire ce décalage vous êtes quand même
ou encore assez loin de votre étiage
normal
vous avez tout à fait raison il ya en a
connu un début de campagne très
difficile quand j'ai été investis et
notre famille politique était donné
autour de 8 ou 9 % dans les sondages
d'opinion aujourd'hui nous sommes
crédités effectivement de 14% des
intentions de vote cela étant dit moi je
ne fais pas campagne le nez collé sur
les sondages je ne me suis pas laissée
intimider par les difficultés du début
je ne me laisse pas non plus grisé par
cette dynamique que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui c'est seulement un élan qui
nous est donnée par tous sur le terrain
mais moi je suis frappé de constater
qu'au delà des sondages ya aussi une
réalité concrète c'est que on l'a vécu
ce soir encore à marseille
les salles sont pleines les gens sont là
il ya une belle ferveur qui n'est
aujourd'hui dans cette campagne et je
suis sûr qu'on peut continuer à
travailler pour rassembler le plus
possible de français autour de cette
vision de l'europe comporte parce que
c'est cette vision qui est nécessaire
pour pouvoir monsieur bd notre pays à se
rétablir dans le monde on dit qu'il se
passe quelque chose autour de votre
campagne
mais comment comptez-vous faire revenir
ces centristes droite ou modérés qui est
tenté aujourd'hui par un vote macro nist
je crois que malheureusement et je suis
le premier à le regretter mais
aujourd'hui les français ont tout pour
sortir de l'illusion sur les grands
sujets qui attend de notre pays sur les
grandes réformes à faire
ainsi peu de chemin a été fait nous
sommes maintenant un à deux ans de
mandat du président de la république et
la dépense publique n'a pas baisser la
fiscalité n'a pas vraiment diminué on le
voit aujourd'hui avec ces nouvelles
hausses d'impôts pour les entreprises
pour ceux qui croyaient que le président
de la république pouvait incarner un
nouveau souffle à portée des réformes et
je comprends qu'on ait pu le croire
parce que il fallait espérer que ce soit
l'occasion pour notre pays d'avancer de
dépasser les difficultés qu'il connaît
bien une chose est sûre maintenant
malheureusement je crois que rien de
sérieux ne s'est fait que rien de
sérieux ne se fera et l'un des enjeux de
cette élection européenne s'est aussi de
sortir de cette fausse alternance de
cette fausse alternative entre populiste
et progressistes qui on le voit bien
aujourd'hui n'apporte aucun espoir aux
français c'est je crois aussi notre
grande responsabilité
je ne veux pas à reprocher à monsieur
mac ont toutes les difficultés de notre
pays
chaque famille politique sans aucun
doute il ya sa part elle dure depuis
depuis si longtemps
la grande question c'est comment est ce
qu'on va pouvoir écrire une nouvelle
page et cette nouvelle page on est en
train de la construire et cette élection
européenne on est en est un moment
important
edouard philippe dit ce soir à caen en
meeting avec nathalie l'oiseau nous ne
devons pas aller dans le sens de ceux
qui disent que l'europe menace la france
d' asphyxie l'europe au contraire c'est
notre oxygène
le premier ministre d'accord avec cela
moi je crois nous croyons profondément
que nous avons besoin d'agir en europe
pour pouvoir relever tous les grands
défis de l'avenir
mais nous voyons aussi qu'aujourd'hui
l'europe malheureusement ne parvient pas
à nous renforcer dans la mondialisation
que très souvent elles nous fragilise
que trop souvent
effectivement c'est vrai parfois elle
nous paralyse au lieu de nous aider à
agir mais ça n'est pas une fatalité et
il faut éviter de sombrer dans un faux
débat qui seraient entre eux pour
l'europe qui consisterait à fuir encore
dans le déni de réalité ou contre
l'europe qui consisterait à déconstruire
cette union pourtant nécessaire pour
nous renforcer dans la mondialisation
nous nous avons un projet qui je crois
correspond à l'aspiration d'une très
grande majorité de français tous ceux
que je rencontre depuis le début de
cette campagne me disent nous croyons à
l'europe mais nous croyons qu'il faut
changer la manière dont l'europe se
construit pour qu'elles puissent de
renforcer et c'est ça le coeur de notre
projet et c'est la raison pour laquelle
c'est vrai il faut aller un peu plus
dans le fond des sujets que de s'en
tenir à une sorte de question qu'ils
feraient blanc ou noir pour ou contre
gentil ou méchant populistes ou
progressistes les français savent bien
que ce n'est pas très sérieux et que le
sujet fondamental c'est de savoir
comment on va réorienter l'europe en
profondeur pour qu'elle puisse être plus
efficace monsieur bel ami une dernière
question vous le 26 après l'élection du
26 mai où siégeraient au parlement
européen dans le groupe de la droite
européenne dit ppe est ce que vous y
côtoie ray les élus de monsieur or ban
le chef du gouvernement hongrois
est-ce que vous êtes prêts à cohabiter
avec eux alors que c'est un pays qui ne
respecte pas toutes les libertés
publiques
il faut travailler pour que le dialogue
européen soit clair et franc sur ces
sujets monsieur robben fait parti du ppe
son parti le fidesz est un parti qui a
contribué à sortir la hongrie delà du
totalitarisme soviétique
c'est un parti qui a évidemment toute sa
place au coeur de de la droite
européenne et j'ai eu l'occasion de
rencontrer la tête de liste du fides à
paris il y a quelques jours de cela
maintenant ce qui est certain c'est que
nous n'avons rien à gagner à la
fracturation de l'europe qui menacent de
s'installer si jamais ce clivage entre
progressistes et populiste devait être
étendue à l'échelle européenne on voit
qu'il n'a servi qu'à fracturé la vie
politique française il pourrait demain
casser la dynamique européenne l'europe
vous savez c'est un dialogue exigeant et
parfois difficiles avec des partenaires
avec lesquels nous ne sommes pas
forcément d'accord sur tout mais avec
lesquels nous devons pouvoir avancer si
nous croyons vraiment à l'europe alors
il faut absolument tenter d'éviter de
remplacer le débat par l'anathème et
c'est ce qui est en train de se jouer
dans cette volonté de faire exploser le
le ppe de l'autre côté madame loiseau et
je le regrette ne veut pas nous dire
aujourd'hui qui seront ses alliés au
parlement européen elle ne veut pas dire
aux français dans quel groupe elle sert
à deux ans et c'est un vrai problème de
transparence nous nous avons des alliés
clés nous sommes capables d'avancer sur
ce projet que nous défendons merci
beaucoup françoise avis mais dany merci
d'avoir répondu à nos questions ce soir
en direct sur bfm tv en direct de
marseille